hey guys welcome back I know it's been a
while I've decided I'm going to at least
attempt to start making some content for
this channel again we'll see how it goes
not making any promises but basically
just to get things rolling gonna start
with just some Q&A videos attempt to at
least put out one a week maybe more
often maybe less often we'll just see
but yeah basically if you have any
questions that you want answered just
put them in the comments below
I'll pick whichever one I like the most
make a video on it then if you have more
questions just put them in the comments
of that video yeah so obviously I've
been away for a while just busy with
various things school getting mass my
research review with Eric Helms and Mike
sort of off the ground
putting out content for stronger by
science so yeah YouTube this kind of
fell by the wayside but yeah I'm gonna
attempt to get this thing up and rolling
again so if you have any questions just
put them in the comments below and
hopefully we'll get this train rolling